check this out daily mail the eco
hypocrite jet set i love it stars such
as mark wahlberg jay-z and steven
spielberg lecture us about saving the
planet then use their private jets for
flights that take
just minutes
instead of driving okay
interesting one website has exposed the
eco hypocrites for their not so green
credentials
the twitter handle at celeb jets which i
had never heard of but i know of now
chronicled their journeys over the last
few months with many trips lasting less
than 30 minutes from lift off to landing
less than 30 minutes on the airplane
okay it gets better
wahlberg's plane took flight for just
nine minutes
as it jetted across la while spielberg
clocked in at a staggering 17 minutes
that's a long flight 17. well how what'd
you expect him to do
stop it
it comes after the social media page
outed kylie jenner oh for a 12 minute
flight across california 12 minutes
12 minutes which saw her branded a
climate criminal by furious eco warriors
meanwhile her sister courtney faced a
huge backlash by fans for posting about
carbon emissions in february
yeah does this sound familiar to you
remember we covered uh kim kardashian
and courtney telling you to eat the fake
meat
eat the fake meat the environment
climate the environment
naked you know me
billions
then they hop on their jet
what a bunch of phonies man
what a bunch of phonies these people are
interesting some stats about what these
flights do because you know when it
comes to carbon emissions you may not be
familiar with what the difference is
between getting in your car and getting
in one of these planes this was
interesting to me
steven spielberg took this 17-minute
flight on june 29th his 28-mile trip
from amsterdam airport to rotterdam
airport would have taken him just 36
minutes by car okay
just spoiled so spoiled according to
celebrity jets the flight used 145
gallons of jet fuel can you imagine cost
him one thousand eleven dollars for the
fuel and resulted in two tons
of co2 emissions
two tons of co2 emissions
now you might say well
how does he feel about global warming
well that's an interesting question that
you asked me speaking about his new
movie ready player one in 2018 spielberg
said this
i'm terrified of global warming
global warming is a scientific reality
it's not a political trick
it's a true piece of real measurable
quantifiable
science
so
okay
these people get on television and they
tell you what to do
they tell you oh you you need to you
need to stop eating that grass-fed
grass-finished beef and instead eat this
crap that has 75 ingredients that i
can't even pronounce
because you know
the environment global warming
and then they hop into jet and do that
so are you done listening yet
are you done listening please in the
chat how does this stuff strike you when
celebrities do this tell me i want to
know
and the list goes on and on rapper drake
beyonce and jay-z
uh there was another article that talked
about kylie jenner i think she had taken
at one point a flight that was three
minutes
i mean like why
what what is the issue really you know i
don't even understand here look three
minute long flights
and it's interesting if you look at that
article actually i wasn't going to do
this one but thank you for reminding me
tyler you look at the comments
there's some beautiful stuff going on
there
just vibes here it says kylie jenner out
here picking which color private jet she
want to take today meanwhile i gotta
chug my iced coffee before my straw
becomes paper mache because you know
they like the paper straws you ever use
a paper straw now listen i do have an
alternative straw that i like because i
don't like the plastic because you know
it leeches the separate conversation
but they want you to use those those
cardboard straws you're drinking it
everything's cool for the first couple
of minutes then suddenly it's like
the the the drinks not coming through
it's all pressed together and nasty
you're eating all that oh i'm swallowing
it she you know that she wants you to do
but she can't get in the car for 15
minutes she's got to get on the plane
you know why she wants a photo op
you saw the picture she posted on
instagram of her and travis and it's
like which which ride should we take or
something is like playing here and
playing there ostentatious in there
in there you know wealth which is fine
you made listen
you made a lot of money
we get it more power to you it's not my
money it's your money more power to you
stop telling other people to live like
rats
right with their paper straws and their
like
meat that has zero nutrient density or
their bugs
i wonder did she sum bugs on the flight
it's three minutes you could down some
caterpillar did she eat bugs did she
take some daring did courtney bring over
some daring meat
and they just popped it in the microwave
and this woman commented on that on the
ig account as well why do i have to
limit my meat consumption and use paper
straws when the one percent gets to pump
tons of carbon into the atmosphere for a
day trip to palm springs so i loved the
comments
uh because people are starting to wake
up you know because it was one thing
when you were just doing your thing and
you were a hypocrite
but now it's like you're telling other
people to do stuff that's bad for them
that's going to harm them that's going
to hurt them that's not good for them
that makes them live makes their quality
of life go down and you're just living
it up
you know what you get pissed enough i
have an idea
stop watching the kardashians
first of all the show sucks
i love reality tv okay i'm gonna say it
again i loved naked and afraid awesome
show a survivor fear factor
i even love the netflix shows uh i love
the love is blind i'll even tune in to
the bachelor that [ __ ] is funny we're
gonna get into some of that on one show
i gotta break down this season it's too
much two girls compete for the same guys
whoo
there's gonna be some spice
i love reality tv the kardashians suck
the show sucks
it's boring
it's really really really painfully
boring it's not reality tv it's pretty
obvious it's all stage everybody's all
made up
you want to watch some reality tv go
back to the jersey shore in the
beginning
that was cool
now i don't even think that's real
anymore i got to ask my friend vinnie
he's probably not going to tell me the
truth but
it's boring you want to send a message
don't buy like six pounds of her
cosmetic line or don't you know you're
tired of these celebrities doing this
[ __ ] just tune them out be like yeah i'm
not buying your [ __ ] anymore i'm tired
of this [ __ ]
that's how you make your message heard
your purchasing power
don't turn on don't sit watch the
kardashians be lining your eyes with her
eyeliner and be like oh this [ __ ] she
lies to me
she'll keep lying
cashing in and guess what maybe next
year she'll get a second private jet
which was like i don't know how many 70
million dollars or something she paid
for it while she tells you to eat you
know i don't know what's next ladybugs
roasted
add a little soy sauce you won't know
the difference if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]